what's up guys we're back here in
Anaheim we're going to the trampoline
park this is the second time and pretty
much a week that we've been here because
I had to conquer my fear now I need to
tell you guys why I'm afraid of
trampolines mostly because when I was
younger I used to sprained my ankles all
the time so I have this fear of
spreading them I spent most of my
childhood and ankle braces when I'd be
playing sports and it was awful oh
really yes and guess what we're doing
after this Olive Garden Jen you ready
today and ready for this ready come and
get it you guys are like six months late
on that one can't believe I'm back here
again this is crazy the stinky socks are
a lifesaver
guys are so happy so tired
Santa I don't believe you anymore one
song Punky's that's all I think stooping
back to this you all gone and all the
slips are empty rows see you stand up
I'll be forgiven I waiting for you
you
you're not
that can happen maybe nothing will
happen maybe something cool will happen
maybe we'll end up in the hospital with
that waiver say
I'm not gonna
she's never been
pictures of you and me we were holding
hands we used to be so the water break
of people I'm going on my phone see ya
Santa Obi
No
one can go
right now we're playing pig I set the
treasure okay I can't do that either
it's gonna be good I'm gonna hit big
like you still hot fun oh I get to set
the trick
all right
my arms are at bat oh yeah
how's your day been
it's good man I getting some flips in
trying to get a little space to do some
back flips but it's a little crowded so
you having a lot of fun at the
trampoline park today there's a lot of
people here so it's been kind of hard to
really do anything as it goes the last
time but having a good time
like some work
double jumps are too scary
let's go time to go God the smell of
Auntie Anne's Pretzels is just the most
amazing thing ever so we just left
trampoline park it was definitely not as
fun as last time because Matt injured
himself and there was a lot of people
that we really couldn't jump from foot
highlighted a few you're consistent now
yeah I'm pretty excited about it
now we're gonna be going to the Olive
Garden and it's Jordans first time at
the Olive Garden yep oh yeah I've even
Melbourne he's gotta sit down for a
second that's not what I like going in
here Oh sushi in Tokyo right like the
deck quality it's something along those
lines
okay so let's remember food jours like
sushi like well guess what all of there
does not have sushi there so oh it's
okay but you said they have pizza pizza
is always good they did a pizza and
pasta
do you like salad on occasion I like
Chinese chicken salad which doesn't
sound very old gardening I don't like to
have that Oh we'll see I'm sure I'll
find something I like
pastas generally good yeah that's not
well I think he's help dude he's not
much pain he did he did you a bad fall
he did that fall
my legs hurt my whole body hurts
actually nice nice face summary yeah oh
oh screams cheers to the freakin week
again Tuesday
oh this was initially for two people yep
you know some no I'm delegating too
because I don't think you can safely
consume that much oh no oh wow anyone
happy birdday what is your name Jenna
all right whoa happy birthday dear Jenna
happy birthday
I think Matt's contemplating whether or
not to come over and drive cars he wants
to he does but there might be some
tiredness I don't think my back can take
the McCleary right we had a lovely time
at all Gard now we're heading back
because we're all in pain and tired ah
like I'm getting out of the foam beat
again
oh my god oh do it you can do this you
got this oh we're good cousin battle has
failed to release any sort of update
from their monitors we had to we had to
resort to something else